well he hasn't even been on the job for
a week but already new Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is promising to help
the State Department get their quote
swagger back just how does he plan to do
that
of course Donna Richardson reports
Secretary Mike Pompeo is first day at
State Department headquarters addressing
the employees he'll lead executing
American foreign policy the United
States diplomatic corps needs to be in
every corner every stretch of the world
executing missions on behalf of this
country this is a typical address for an
incoming Secretary of State unusual that
Pompeo has already led a high-level
diplomatic mission to Belgium for NATO
meetings and then Saudi Arabia Israel
and Jordan the United States strongest
allies in the region I think I have the
record for the longest trip to the first
day of work and I am I am humbled to be
here I I tried to prepare myself for
this moment but to stand here and look
at the most important diplomatic core in
the world is enormous ly humbling to me
for this West Point graduate diplomacy
extends beyond fighting in Afghanistan
and Ukraine and threats from Iran in
North Korea the Trump administration is
also trying to alter economic
relationships president Trump has
dispatched a delegation to China his top
economic advisors with sometimes very
different strategies to address the
nearly four hundred billion dollar
annual trade deficit with China forced
transfers of American technology to
Chinese companies and tariffs and
restraints on American imports the Trump
administration is also pushing for trade
concessions from European and North
American allies the White House is
delaying for one-month tariffs on
imported steel and aluminum from Canada
Mexico and the European Union we are
extending those negotiations because
we've seen some progress I'm not gonna
get ahead of what that may look like but
we have 30 days to continue in those
negotiations and hopeful that we can get
something that works for everybody in a
statement the European Commission says
quote the u.s. decision prolongs market
uncertainty which is already affecting
business decisions as a long-standing
partner and friend of the u.s. we
will not negotiate under threat though
German officials say they want to reach
an agreement confess Stefania but I
firmly believe that in the best interest
of jobs in Germany in Europe but also in
the United States we need a permanent
arrangement and that increasing tariffs
is the wrong way forward
the US has Trade Representative Robert
light Heiser says he hopes in the coming
weeks to conclude those ongoing
negotiations to update NAFTA he plans on
meeting with counterparts from Mexico in
Canada next week just as soon as he
returns from these trade talks in China
Brett Richardson live at the State
Department rich thank you